>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Good afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
My name is Talia Guzman-Gonzalez
and I am a reference librarian
and Luso-Brazilian specialist
in the Hispanic Division.
It is my great pleasure to
have you all here to talk
about Exile, Diaspora,
and Return:
Changing Cultural Landscapes
in Argentina, Chile,
Uruguay, and Paraguay.
A team research project by
Luis Roniger, Leonardo Senkman,
Saúl Sosnowski, and
Mario Sznajder.
Today we have with us two
of the authors of the book,
two of the team members, Luis
and Saúl, who will be talking
with Professor Juan
Uriagereka from the Department
of Linguistics and
Professor Ernesto Calvo
from the Department of
Government and Politics,
both at the University
of Maryland College Park.
I'm going to briefly introduce
Professors Roniger and Sosnowski
and then I'm going to pass
the microphone to Saúl
who will be the emcee
for the event.
Luis Roniger is Reynolds
Professor
of Latin American Studies
at Wake Forest University.
He is a comparative political
sociologist and his work focuses
on the interface
between politics,
society, and public culture.
He has published numerous
journal articles and books
on a vast range of topics
including human rights,
transitional politics, exile
and democracy in Latin America.
Professor Roniger is the author
of "Destierro y exilio
en America Latina,
Nuevos estudios y avances
teoricos" published
by the University of
Buenos Aires in 2014,
and "Tres estudios sobre el
exilio: Condicion humana,
experiencia historica y
significacion politica",
co-author with Arturo Aguirre
and Antolin Sanchez in 2014 too,
and also "Transnational Politics
in Central America"
published in 2011.
Saúl Sosnowski is
currently professor
of Latin American Literature
and Culture at the University
of Maryland in College Park
besides having held many other
administrative positions
such as Director
of the Latin American Studies
Center which he founded in 1989.
Professor Sosnowski has been
the force we had many important
initiatives in academic projects
such as a decade-long series
of international conferences,
"The Repression of Culture
and its Reconstruction
in the Southern Cone".
He is the founder and editor
of the literary journal
Hispania, currently--
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Hispamerica.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Hispamerica, sorry.
Yeah. Currently in what,
currently in what
issue, what-- Saúl?
>> Saúl Sosnowski: 47th year.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
47th year.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Yeah.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzalez:
Amazing.
And I lost where I was.
Thank you.
His work centers on issues
of civic education, democracy
and conflict management
and cultural politics
with the focus on Latin America.
He is the author of "Julio
Cortaza: una busqueda mitica",
"Borges y la Cabala:
la busqueda del Verbo",
currently in its third edition
and translated into Portuguese
and German, and "La orilla
imminente: escritores judios-
argentinos, Fascismo y nazismo
en las letras argentinas"
with Leonardo Senkman,
and "Cartografia de las
letras hispanoamericanas:
tejidos de la memoria".
Please join me in welcoming
our distinguished guests
to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Saúl Sosnowski:
Thank you, Talia.
And through you I would also
like to thank Georgia Durham
for the arrangements and for
the invitation to be able
to present Exile,
Diaspora, and Return:
Changing Cultural Landscapes
in Argentina, Chile, Paraguay,
and Uruguay, a book that was
produced by four colleagues.
I was going to say quatro
amigos, then the reference is
to tres amigos and we are in the
[inaudible] pick for two room
and this is leading
us someplace else.
And the four of us, Luis
Roniger, a sociologist,
Mario Sznajder, a
political scientist,
Leonardo Senkman a historian,
and I from the literary side,
have been working on
these kinds of issues
from different vantage points
and different perspectives
for quite a while.
And we decided at some point
that it would be a good idea
to approach a neglected area,
what we consider the
neglected area of research
about which my colleagues will
be speaking a little later.
So the first meeting took
place as many meetings
of this sort take place
in Jerusalem and it--
or the Hebrew University
of Jerusalem
on the Mount Scopus Campus.
And once we decided that we were
going to engage in this product,
in this project that
turned out to be a product,
we held meetings in different
parts of Latin America as well
as here and more
than once in Israel.
And this was due to the
fact that we were very lucky
to obtain the support from the
Binational Science Foundation
Israel to US that allowed us
to carry out this research
which mandated several trips in
order to interview a whole array
of people in each of
the four countries,
and more about that
a little later.
The transition to democracy
in each case was subject
to very radically different
approaches and conditions
which in turn conditioned and
affected the process of return,
the policies to promote
such a return and the impact
that returnees have had on
the respective countries.
And this is a subject that
I'm sure will be touched upon
by our colleagues.
I think it is worth
noting that though none
of the four authors currently
live in our birthplace,
three of us are from Argentina
and even the Chilean among
us was born in Buenos Aires
but he opted for
becoming a Chilean,
a common mistake by some people.
One of our defining
identities is clearly anchored
in the region.
Objective analysis in carrying
out research has been
a guiding principle,
but so I sense it's a sense
of commitment that each one
of us has to the region, sort
of a necessary unavoidable
commitment to both memory
and to the unfolding present.
I'm very grateful to two of my
colleagues from the University
of Maryland who have agreed to
speak about some of the issues
that are addressed in the
book, maybe about the book too,
but we'll find out shortly since
both of them have been very,
very active in related issues.
Ernesto Calvo who holds a PhD
from Northwestern University is
a professor and associate chair
in the Department of
Government and Politics
at the University of Maryland.
His research on political
representation, elections
and congresses has
received numerous awards.
He is the author of "Legislator
Success in Fragmented Congresses
in Argentina" published
by Cambridge University
Press in 2014.
"La nueva politica de Partidos"
by Prometeo years
before in 2005.
And relatively-- recently
"Anatomia Politica de Twitter en
Argentina: tuiteando #Nisman",
a project that gathered
the attention of many
of our graduate students
at College Park.
He's currently conducting
research and patronage networks,
co-sponsorship networks
and representation.
Ernesto Calvo will
be going first.
But in order to make it
a smoother transition,
let me introduce already
Juan Uriagereka who says
that whatever I'm going
to be telling you right now
really does not represent him.
And in a way it's sort of true
because he's a lot more
done what I'm going
to be reading to you.
But that is the case of
our other friends also.
He is a linguist who has
joined the University
of Maryland in 1989.
I must say that when he
joined Maryland, he also came
in a joint appointment with
Spanish and Portuguese.
Later he drifted
towards linguistic,
but that mistake will be
remedied effective this coming
fall when he will become part
of the Department of Spanish
and Portuguese while
maintaining his affiliation
with linguistics.
He has published a dozen books
on language structure
including two textbooks,
"The Minimalist Program"
and its precursors,
as well as many articles
and chapters.
He is a founding member of
the Linguistics Department.
And in his capacity as
Associate Provost for Faculty,
a post he held for quite a few
years, he lead the approval
and promotion of
family-friendly policies,
regularizing the status of
professional track faculty,
organizing leadership forums
and updating promotion
and tenure policies.
His current book
projects include the books
"Biolinguistic Investigations on
the Formal Language Hierarchy",
a monograph in progress and
structure with Howard Lasnik,
and a multidisciplinary project
to formulate language structures
as linear operators of the sort
employed in machine learning.
Having said that, which
sounds very technical,
the most important part is
that when he came to Maryland,
he said it works with
both sides of his brain.
And he is a fiction writer.
And not just-- and we have a
few things cooking along the way
that, well, maybe a little
presentation here one day.
We'll see.
Gentlemen, thank you first of
all for agreeing to be here
and the floor is yours, Ernesto.
[ Applause ]
>> Ernesto Calvo: So first,
thank you so much
for the invitation.
And I love the book, so
it's a nice book to present.
I do have to say that it's a
bit of a self-serving likeness
of the book because there's
a lot of things that happened
in the book and there are a
lot of things that are related
that actually go to
my personal life.
So let me start by pointing to a
couple of anecdotes that I think
that highlight I think
what's a true contribution
at least for me of the book.
So we're having common
Lazaro Cardenas,
[inaudible], the Dow Jones, MTV.
So let me start with a story.
So when-- in 1976 my family
went to Mexico on exile.
My mother is [inaudible] and
pretty much the entire side
of my family went to either
Mexico, Spain or Venezuela.
So, most of the exile community
which is actually told here,
you know, with the kids,
they put kids in communities
and we were connected to
each other, we form networks.
The kind of networks that are--
we're able to describe
in the book
that have been persisting
for, you know,
40 years at this point.
So when a lot of us
went to one school
that was called [inaudible].
Maybe some of you,
if you're connected
to the Afghan-Mex
committee heard about it.
And in the [inaudible] we would
have practices that we would go
to the countryside in Mexico.
The first one that
we went was to do--
to analyze wood production
in Mexico in Michoacán.
At the time the governor
of Michoacán was
Cuauhtémoc Cárdenas.
And his son, Lazaro Cardenas
was actually a classmate
of my brother.
And because he was the
son of the governor,
he organized the meeting so
that we could put our tents
in the government
house the first day
because then we would
go to the area
that wood was being produced.
So the first night when we
were in the government mansion,
outside in the gardeners
with our tents,
we start to hear
some odd noises.
So we come out, several
of us, and start to hear
that something was
going on in the tent.
And tent was Lazaro Cardenas
with one of our teachers,
which was also a
refugee from Uruguay.
And outside of the tent was,
you know a lot my friends
that was the son of Pepe Perez
[assumed spelling] which is one
of the historians at the time,
historians for most
historians was the--
the director of the
museum archeology
and he was [inaudible] which was
the stepson of [inaudible] also
in the book which later wrote
the discourse of [inaudible]
and then was [inaudible].
So it was about twelve of
us from Chile, from Uruguay,
from Argentina because a lot
of the community in exile puts
in kids in sort of
the same school.
And it was a school on the
left political spectrum.
We would organize
politically there.
And we have formed strong
bonds and you would see
that through layers
of generations
that would call our [inaudible]
and we would be the, you know,
sons and daughters of the
people who went in exile.
So the book is really good.
I'm describing something
that generally has not been
well portrayed which is
that exiles are of very
different kinds and they're--
the sort of terror
and destruction
that triggers the situation
exile does not necessarily
continues in the
same way, you know.
In a way eventually exile
for many other people
that I know became
a source of pride,
a source of community building.
And most of us remain connected.
So when there earthquake
hit Mexico last year,
we were calling all of
our friends in Mexico.
And when one of our classmates
was kidnapped by the--
by Pinochet in 1997, we were
demonstrating in Argentina.
We were demonstrating in Chile.
We were demonstrating
in Mexico and Uruguay.
So this community started
to produce very significant
networks
that connected our countries
and that remains the case.
We have, you know, friends that
are musicians that are playing
in Mexico and some of them
are actually faculty here
in California, in MIT,
some of them-- my friends.
That's not me.
And so, then--
>> Which I turned it off.
>> Ernesto Calvo: Santiago Perez
I was saying for example ended
up being the director of
Dow Jones for Latin America,
[inaudible] ended
up in MTV as a--
one of the creatives of
MIT-- MTV doing publicity.
So every one of those remained
connected to the network
and we have our own Facebook
page which is [inaudible]
where we connect and track
each other's history.
The source and pride and glory
of the school is Chivo Lubezki
which is, you know, the one
that won three Oscars
for cinematography.
That was actually was a Mexican.
So and-- so one of
the interesting things
about the book is it starts
by narrating exile not just
as a source of a terror, demise,
death, sort of their picture
that you have from there
Nacional Buenos Aires
where a lot of you have
seen these pictures,
a very classic picture
of [inaudible],
a picture of the class of
1975 in the Buenos Aires,
most of which ended
up in exile or death.
So that's a picture that most
of the narratives of
exiles begin with.
But what they don't say
is what happen afterwards,
which is how these
communities start to build roots
and they start to
become very transnational
and start operating a very large
number of countries socially,
culturally, politically, and
start to engage in activities
that will signify exile
and turn it into something
that is pretty different.
So the book, what it does
that I think is wonderful is
rebuilding those later networks.
OK. How these people that
were on exile are reabsorbed,
are reintegrated, how two things
are at the core of the community
in exile that is returning?
One, they come back
with political capital,
with social capital,
with cultural capital
that allows them
to give a narrative
about both the dictatorship,
exile.
The other one is that
it produces a network
that overlays the network
in Latin America where all
of Latin America is
touched by notes.
So all of us have networks
in the other countries
and are connected with
the Onam in Mexico
or with the [inaudible] in
Mexico, FPB, the [inaudible].
You know, all the different
institutions have actually
members of exile.
And it's not just the Argentina
exiles, the Argentina exiles,
the Uruguayan exiles,
the Chilean exile.
Twenty out of 22 countries
of Latin America had
authoritarian regimes
when we moved to Mexico.
And Mexico was a big hub.
Most of those countries
that were authoritarians
produced communities that left
to Italy as they described, to
Venezuela, to Spain, to France.
And all of us remain connected
because it was not different
families to different places.
Oftentimes, we actually
have members in, you know,
each one of those places.
So as I was saying, you know,
my family goes in exile.
We went to Mexico.
One of my uncles
went to Venezuela,
another one of my
uncles went to Spain.
Then they moved to Spain,
the ones from Venezuela.
Then all my cousins ended up
in the US doing academic work.
And generally, I spend a couple
of months in a year in Argentina
and maybe a month in the
other places in the region.
And by rebuilding
these other structures
that characterize
the exile, what--
what they do is to bring what
we actually remember from exile.
Most of the pictures of exile
depict what happens with,
you know, at the
time of departure.
You know, the fact that my
father was in jail when he comes
out and we're going to exile.
He actually produces-- an entire
operation to try to cover us
so that nothing would happen
when we were exiting
the country.
We arrived to Mexico and
everything is depleted.
But over two, or
three, or four years,
these networks actually
starts to build things
that are extremely interesting,
and starts to build catalog
that was impossible to being
thought about later on.
So in-- when in-- the
discussion, decision for example
to go back to Argentina,
they hit right
on the nail of the segregation.
We had huge discussions
about where to go,
when to go, what to go for.
So for example three months
after democratization,
I went back to Argentina
but my parents were not
willing to do so yet.
Not without knowing that
the situation was going
to be politically stable.
So I arrived to Argentina,
15-year-old,
living on basically my community
or, you know, kids and parents
from exile that are
returning in different stages
and that are producing
the same kind of--
building bridges that we had
in Mexico when we arrived.
So the networks starts
to be staged both going
forward and coming backward.
And at the same time we have
some friends that had said
to go back to Argentina
that once they're
in Argentina realized that there
is no longer a political goal
that they actually can sustain
or are willing to defend.
So some of them go back to
Mexico or ended up in the US.
So you start to see these sort
of very different patterns
of migration that carried and
networks have been created
to a very large number
of places.
So, each one of the chapters
is actually reconstructing part
of those debates.
Debates about should we
accept for example payment
for the hardships that
we face in an exile?
There was a huge discussion
in the community whether
reparations should be accepted
and we were very divided.
We didn't want to
accept reparations
but at the same time
other people wanted
to accept reparations
and the decision
to it was very personal, but
it was discussed collectively
as our problem in our community.
The same happened with
the recent reparations.
My father received one
but at the same time,
it was a huge discussion whether
you should receive reparations
for having been in prison
under-- or repent, you know,
the national executive.
So these sort of discussions are
building political narratives
that do not have to do
with the crimes committed
by the dictatorship and do not
have to do with the conditions
in which we left to the exile.
But actually daily
political life
of constructing networks
once you are
in this position to accept.
And that's I think what
makes this book different.
Most of the other books,
they're not that many,
but most of the other books
that I've seen, what they tried
to do is to reconstruct the
source of the destruction
of this community knowing
and then consider how then
they say exile accentuates your
natural craziness, which
is absolutely true.
We were all absolutely insane
in many different ways just
so that you have
a taste of that.
For a few months, I
would go into stores,
big stores like we had
Liverpool and stole things.
And before getting to the door,
I would actually leave them
by the door so that when I
was obtained by the police,
I would actually start
shouting at them.
We were very insane,
maybe different ways.
But the interesting thing
is that this actually builds
into networks that produce
interesting political results.
And we're-- there's
reparation, a certain reparation
that is done by the
community and by the networks
that are formed in
the community.
I think that's a wonderful
result of the book.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Uriagereka:
I have to apologize
because I'm not a professional,
so I wrote some notes
just to think about this.
I was born in the '50s
in a normal Spanish
family from Spain.
President Eisenhower had
just ended the blockade
that had us start
after the Great War.
The alternative to invading with
Hitler in Mussolini defeated.
It wouldn't have been easy
for the French or British
who hadn't been willing to
stop fascism in its inception.
Stalin was eager too but fearing
the west wanted the Soviets
controlling the Mediterranean.
Well over half a million people
had died in the Civil War,
Spanish Civil War,
including 200,000 executed
in the [inaudible] and
other 50,000 were killed
after the war ended.
Several thousand more died
in concentration camps.
This is all in Spain.
Some 200,000 became
permanent exiles.
By the 1970s, about 4 million
had immigrated once it became
legal in the 1940s in a
country of 27 million,
again get the percentages.
As I said, my family was normal.
Some had survived the bombing of
Guernica that Picasso depicted.
Others recounted that
in similar stories.
I grew up in my grandparents'
[inaudible] farm
as my father worked
for a company in exile.
Mom learned to read
from another--
from an urban teacher who
was relocated to our hamlet
as a punishment for
having defended democracy.
That was actually a break for
us peasants as he gave her
and my uncles knowledge.
Uncle Luis [assumed
spelling] was 15
when he left for Argentina.
Uncle Antonio, 14, half the
family was already in America.
In my mind, it was difficult to
figure out whether the letters
that relatives sent
home were from exile,
immigration, prison or what.
It was just a distant place.
In the '60s, much
unrest happened
in those remote places
of our relatives.
Dad's company was then working
in Chile from where he wrote
of hope, illegally
mailing books and records
about Che Guevara
and by Violeta Parra.
Practically all the Spanish
writers I read then were exiles.
During our transition to
democracy, many returned
from the Southern Cone
escaping the dictatorships
that we're talking about today.
The book that we are
presenting brought a smile
to my face reminding me of
my literary heroes, Onetti,
Galeano, Benedetti, Perry Rossi
[assumed spelling], Soriano,
Roa Bastos, or actors whose
skill impressed me the most,
Alteri [assumed spelling],
Rossi [assumed spelling],
Politi [assumed spelling].
Not to speak of the
musicians whose songs we sang
in the streets, [inaudible],
Sosa, Guevara,
Warani [assumed spelling].
Our book notes on page
73, the difficulty
that American exiles had in
Europe echoing the complaint
by Perry Rossi that I
remember very vividly.
That being said,
my dearest friends,
were those marginalized
intellectuals.
Some of whom taught
me everything I know
about the theater, like the late
Claudio Narea [assumed spelling]
after learning his
craft from [inaudible].
I can't imagine the
Spanish movie there,
the "Almodóvar" made famous
without the likes
of Cecilia Roth.
And so I can't help asking
what really happened,
why this ties back and forth.
I sent this on page 187.
This is so that you
see I read the book--
reads, "whether clothed in
military or civilian guard,
authoritarianism has
been a mainstay."
While the book is talking
about Latin America,
the motherland is no different.
In the two plus century
since the French Revolution,
one can count 25, 25
military [inaudible].
I don't care whether from
the right or from the left,
military [inaudible]
in 200 years.
The latest one in 1981,
five years before Spain
joined the European Union,
still unclear who was behind it.
During the 19th century, liberal
and conservative administrations
so commonly replace one
another after a coup.
That by the time the
monarchy was reestablished,
they institutionalize
succession of government.
So the opposite side routinely
change in every two years.
Alas, that Solomonic
solution didn't last long
because both were
incredibly corrupt.
Eventually further coups led
to the famous dictatorships
of the 20th century.
As the book describes,
the fate of these dynamics
on page 32 citing Luna
involved [foreign language],
that is prison, expulsion or
entombment, so the dark aspects.
And not all is bad that
stems from such chaos.
It may have been harder to
otherwise realize the liberation
of American and Asian colonies
throughout the 19th century
or the African ones
during the 20th century.
Just as not always good either
in the visionary governments
that stemmed from uprisings
like the French revolution.
The Napoleonic standardization
fueled resentment leading
to successful fascist
nationalisms from Italy
to Germany to unsuccessful ones
from Iberia to the Vulcans.
Later still lingering conflicts.
Look at the Catalan one.
Often find a trigger in
Civil Wars of that ilk.
As David Armitage reminds
us, I am a revolutionary,
you are a rebel, and they
are engaged in the Civil War.
This is why the question
of whether nationalistic
movements are good
or bad has no easy answer.
After all, we describe by
the same word, the Mapuche
or the [inaudible]
nation, and the Russian
and the Chinese nation.
Such dynamics are structure
for me in a deep sense,
and this is the linguist
in me talking now.
Within material science,
physical tensions
of this sort are called
dynamical frustration.
We may think of it as the
unresolvable coexistence
of conflicting tendencies
that never settle.
For those raised in
the Marxist tradition,
dynamical frustration
relates to the Hegelian clash
between thesis and antithesis
except you never achieve
a synthesis.
Or if you wish, the synthesis
is a state of equilibrium
that arises from
the clash itself.
I raised the idea because
yet a further ingredient
in the cauldron, one leading
to the exiles we are now
considering is radicalism
and reaction to liberalism.
It is fascinating how liberal
and radical forces ally
to defeat conservatives
in the form of fascism.
Although, first liberalism
aligned with conservatism
to keep radicalism confined
to the east, Russia and so on.
And less than a decade later,
the logical combination closed
with at least in
Europe conservatism
and radicalism uniting over
how to partition Poland.
In this light, one can read
the second A bomb in Nagasaki
under liberal reluctance to let
Stalin go for Franco and Salazar
as the new dynamical frustration
which crystallizes
into the Cold War.
The book has several
further examples
of dynamical frustration
beyond that Cold War.
We are reminded of the
vicious circle in which fear
of revolution brings
about repression
which fuels the desire
for revolution and so on.
Or different instantiations
of modernity
when the ideological
path concocted
in the west an urban reality
confirms the multifarious nature
of the rural colonial or
frontier realities beyond.
Indeed, these revolutions,
rebellions, civil wars,
whatever you want to call
them that led to the creation
of the very nations
we're talking about,
from the Spanish empire
and from one another.
Those are all prime examples
of dynamical frustration.
All these dynamics
are frustrating
and including the fact
that exile is both
welcomed and threatened.
And this is another
quote from the book,
"You who left are now
returning like heroes and we
who stayed behind are
the ones who suffered."
Those are the inxiles [phonetic]
that are mentioned in the book.
Those are very complicated
dynamics with--
There is no right or wrong here.
The book also interestingly
brings
to the equation the
unintended consequence of exile
in a globalized world.
The media related, university
and culturally driven,
and ultimately politically
effective role of exiles
in making their countries
change.
Another example of this
earlier on is what intellectuals
from Nazi Germany did.
That's one of the main pillars
of the American University.
The book puts it on-- book
on page 26 as followed,
in the long run, exile
backfired given the connections
established by exiles and the
resonance their plight received,
perhaps partly as a result,
while the Spanish dictatorship
lasted four decades, 39 years.
And ones whose effects were
examined with the exception
of Paraguay, which is almost
as long as the Spanish were
between half and a fifth
shorter, depending.
Now, that allowed for larger
role of the exiled communities.
That's what chapter
7 mainly is about.
And what chapter 5 goes into,
procedures for repatriation
that we were discussing,
investigation,
eventually fair trials, again,
with the interesting
exception of Paraguay.
Situation in Spain
aligns more with Paraguay
than the more democratic
Argentinean nations.
Argentina, Chile and
especially Uruguay
where you have a former diplomat
are becoming the head of state.
For a member of a
comparable armed group--
armed group in Spain, that
would be just unthinkable.
Indeed, the moral
debate about arm struggle
that chapter 6 raises, extremely
interesting, inconceivable
in a country that only a
couple of weeks ago was ruled
against by the European
Court of Human Rights
for jailing activists
after burning effigies
of the king whose role in the
coup d'etat is still murky.
Despite the fact that as
the book notes on page 70,
Southern Cone exiles had a hard
time explaining their messy
politics to Europeans.
This is still the case.
It's very difficult
to understand
by European standards.
Spanish exiles with a more
traditional message were not
able to summon action
against Franco who died in bed
and as he wished, leaving
things very well bounded.
To this date, speaking in
Spain not just of reparation
or restoration, but even
investigation is taboo.
It is presently inconceivable
to find a situation equivalent
to what the book discusses
on page 149 where the day
of the national stop rising in
Spain turns into a national day
of memory, truth and justice
as is the case in
the Southern Cone.
Chapter 8 speaks of shifting
frontiers of citizenships,
exploring transnational
networks,
topic that fascinates me.
This can be seen as
a new phenomenon.
Describing present migratory
processes, this is a quote
as having complicated, the
possibility of defining diaspora
in purely ethnonational terms.
But this is now me.
I would say modern notions
like nation itself are liberal
inventions of the 19th century,
while Diasporas are many, many,
many tens of thousands
of years older.
Before the birth
of nation states,
those were immigration dynamics,
not conquest ones
for the most part.
Now, mere emigrants built
humanity as we understand it.
Interbreeding for example with
Neanderthals and Denisovans
to yield the miracles
of art and myth.
Those errant Jews and gypsies
and aborigines and Indians
and other expatriates
of all kinds,
those are the holders
of human existence.
Only very slow time in evolution
will tell whether it's dynamical
frustrations lead to
emergent structures
that we may call
forward thinking.
Certainly new realities
will emerge that way too.
Witness the web,
witness social media.
The way art did-- and
eventually writing,
and eventually the printing
press, all as momentous
as the internet these days.
In our world, it may not be
all that bad to start dreaming
of electronic exiles,
because one runs
out of physical locations to
take the children to in case
of real and tangible
civil wars or familiar
and not electronic prisons.
Thinking of normal families in
Syria, Iraq does make me wonder.
Our book cites Perry Rossi's
line representing the dilemma
of exile, "to part
is to part in half."
It echoes the one
line that Cole Parker,
adapting that unforgettable
goodbye,
which is to die a little.
Then again, the horrors
we continue to witness
in other authoritarian
societies remind us
that to die is to part a lot.
So let's hope that
before the finale exile,
we leave our children in a
more democratic, transparent,
pluralistic world of the sort
our dear exiles fought for,
successfully in that
they kept our hope alive.
This is one tangible legacy
of this wonderful book.
Well beyond the accurate facts
and testimonies in regard
to institutional transformation.
As it notes on page
187, electoral democracy
and the periodic change
of government seem
to have taken a firm hold.
It is uplifting to see such
a comprehensive analysis
of exile placed in the context
and exploring without anger,
even nostalgia, how it
contribute to the development
of democracy in countries
where that exile originated
and in countries like
my own where it ended.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: If
Roniger should join us.
I could hear his comments.
So let me tell you
something about,
one of the difficulties
in writing this book.
There are four of us,
as I mentioned before
from different disciplines,
with writing habits
that are very far
one from the other.
And Luis Roniger and Mario
Sznajder collaborated
on a number of books, so they
knew each other fairly well.
Leonardo Senkman and I wrote
one book together about fascism
and Nazism in Argentine letters.
But Leo Senkman has one way of
writing and one way of thinking
that is about, I don't
know, whether 180 degrees,
but at least 90 degrees
away from my own.
And that was one of
the difficulties,
trying to find a common
voice, how are we going
to find some sort of language
that will accommodate
the perspectives
from which we were coming.
The other thing is each one of
us has a very different style
of work and there
is one among us
who is the most workaholic
of all.
No, it's not me.
It is Luis Roniger.
And he is the one who
really kept us in line.
And so, in addition to all the
merits of his scholarly work
and so on, I have to tell
you that he is really--
I don't want to say slave
driver, it's not nice,
but he's the one who kept
us on track and partly it's
because he also has a secret
weapon, his wife Shirley
who is the one who also
did the index for the book,
a rather awesome task for which
all authors are most grateful
to you, Shirley.
Thank you.
Let me turn this over to
Luis and who is partly
to a good degree
responsible for the fact
that we were able
to finish this book.
Luis.
>> Luis Roniger: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Luis Roniger: Thank you,
Saúl, for your kind words.
And thank you Ernesto and Juan
for the generous evaluation,
talk about the book
and also sharing your
personal perspective.
And listening to you, I would
like to say that what is exile
and what is the key that
brings such creativities,
such innovation, not just to
the countries that we analyze
but overall there is an open
possibility that [inaudible].
And the idea of exile is that
at least in the modern world,
it breaks the hyphen
between nation and state.
Whenever people are forced
to flee their own countries,
they are no longer obligated.
They cannot take the markers
of that certainty for granted.
They cannot take their
common assumptions
for granted, something
has broken.
In the nation state,
collective identity
and political rights
are built together.
This is the hyphen
between nation and state.
But once they leave, they
cling even more to the nation
but they are no longer
committed to the state.
And these open a range of
possibilities of learning,
of getting to use new-- getting
used to new institutions,
new forms of interacting,
new forms of partnership,
even the very conception of
being in a relationship changed.
And as you know, many in exile
have eventually broken apart
diverse as being a
characteristic of--
thank you, diverse as being
a characteristic of exile.
And there are many losses of
exile, but there are also gains.
This possibility of opening
themselves to new ideas,
to new forms of understanding
the world,
understanding politics pays off.
Because together
with the losses,
and losses certainly are
numerous and countless
and have been a-- both
in personal terms,
in terms of the life
of people going
to exile, many, many losses.
But also gains not just
individually, not just in terms
of human capital but things
that will eventually come
to serve the countries
of origin.
People will remain
attached to their countries,
to their background and
once the possibility opens,
they should consider
whether to return.
And though-- although
the return, the word,
is in the title of the book, we
emphasized throughout the book
that this is just one
possibility among many.
And therefore there are
not just the returnees
that we should consider.
There are the sojourners
that people who stay abroad
but maintain relationship
with others in the diaspora.
And let me-- beyond
the individual gains,
it mentioned something about the
contributions to the country.
Let's start with politics.
We cannot understand the
transition from authoritarianism
to democracy in some
of those countries
without considering exile.
The most evident
case among the four
that we consider is
the case of Chile.
In Chile, exiles were
crucial in the transition
but because they were
crucial while in exile,
they recompose the
political alliances,
the socialist change
their attitude,
broke ranks with the communist.
Within the communist
there were also divisions.
Eventually they build a
coalition of 17 countries.
This is called the [inaudible]
that led to the defeat
of Pinochet in the
referendum of 1998
and eventually opened
the door to transition.
But also in the cabinet of the
successive governments that came
after the transition, exiles
played a crucial role.
Even-- in terms of their numbers
among the cabinet members you
can trace exiles.
They were a prevailing force.
In Uruguay for example, Danilo
Astori, the vice president
of President Mujica
was an exile.
The minister of education,
Ricardo Ehrlich was an exile.
They were also scientists,
but they moved
into politics beyond
the politics
of the university
then in academia.
In academia in Uruguay
for example,
until 1984 there was just
one university, the UdelaR,
Universidad de la Republica,
exiles opened a range
to new universities, new
disciplines, new investment
in science and technology.
For example in biology, in
the biological sciences,
there were five tenure position
before the exiles returned.
As exiles started returning,
they build a faculty of 100,
over 100, they invested
millions.
They used their connections
with France,
with Mexico to create
new avenues,
new subdisciplines,
et cetera, et cetera.
Three of the four provosts in
Uruguay following the return
of democracy were exiles,
and some of them were very,
very instrumental in revamping
the entire educational system
of higher ed-- entire system
of higher education in Uruguay
in the realm of new disciplines.
For example in Chile there
was no social history
until Gabriel Salazar
returned to Chile.
Bioethics, in Argentina
there was no sense
of what is the ethics in
dealing with biological research
until somebody who did
his career in the US,
Victor Penchaszadeh,
returned to Argentina
and opened a new ground
supporting also the mothers
and especially the
grandmothers of Plaza de Mayo
and eventually created
a new field
of research and investigation.
In the publishing industry,
in each of the four countries,
you can find people who
recreated the impetus
that existed in the
'60s once back
in their countries after exile.
Let me mentions some of them.
Divinsky in Ediciones de
la Flor en in Argentina.
Pablo Harari, he founded
Editorial Trilce in Uruguay.
Carlos Orellana in Chile.
In the case of Paraguay,
[inaudible] by himself
on its own effort, as you
know Paraguay is a totally
different universe.
It's a universe of
an oral culture,
not necessarily a
written culture.
But he managed somehow to
eventually fail in the long run
because Paraguay is Paraguay
with not enough readership,
but he tried so hard.
And other people who did not
go into exile collaborated
with people in exile,
exiles coming back.
And for instance the
first-- a film, a long--
a feature film in Paraguay
was done by a returnee.
"Miramenometokei" was the
name of this film in 2002.
And also, there were failures of
course, institutional failures.
One may ask why the democracy
in Uruguay or democracy
in Chile seems to have overcome
to a larger extent
the polarization,
political polarization down
the democracy in Argentina.
A part of this story is
that the contributions
of exiles is not enough.
It is the meeting point between
the ability of the exiles,
the willingness to do
something for the country
and eventually the
long-term conditions
that enable those
contributions to be pervasive
or be fleeting away
and disappear.
In the case of Argentina,
we have with initial
democratization starting
on December of 1983, we have
very important contributions
in science for example
with Sadosky
which democratized the
entire system of academia.
They [inaudible] and
try to democratize it,
and that the realm of
politics the group of Esmeralda
who were the advisers
to president Alfonsin
and wrote these discourses
as was mentioned before.
The Cultura Sosyalista that was
supposed to be an open ground--
an open meeting ground for
people to debate the ideas
without political polarization.
Nonetheless, politics are
at large and the connection
between politics and
the political economy
for Argentina failed.
And as you know, there were many
waves and ups and downs both
in transition of justice
and the recreation
of democratic culture.
But nonetheless, the
level of civil society,
the transformation was
there to stay and as a--
and despite the institution
imbalances that we see
in Argentina and
still the tradition
of political polarization,
Argentina of the 2010
is not the same in terms
of embracing human rights.
It has gained a lot
in that support.
I think that political exiling
Latin America has something
to say-- something of
comparative relevance
for other regions of the world.
And we are-- before Juan started
mentioning the case and talking
about the case of Spain
and this brings me--
it brings to my mind
also the case of Germany.
Case of Germany and in
the case of this space.
There's not been a
re-accommodation of exiles
as in the case of
the Southern Cone
and in particular I would
say the case of Uruguay,
then followed by the case of
Chile, the case of Argentina,
and finally the case
of Paraguay.
Various degrees of
accommodation,
but there's been a willingness
somehow after initial period
of resistance to
re-accommodate exiles
and give exiles the
proper place.
Of course Uruguay is at the top
because in the case of Uruguay,
they decided to bring the
people who lose their jobs
in the public administration.
They are called the exonerados.
This was the word that was used.
People who lost their
position, what they were thrown
out of work and then many
of them left for exile.
With democratization, Uruguay
decided to bring them back
to their former positions.
For instance, Samuel
Lichtensztejn who was
in the '70s, in the early
'70s the provost of UdelaR,
of the Universidad-- Universidad
de la Republica was brought back
in the '80s and given
his old post.
Now with a new perspective and
new exposure, a new context,
transnational connections,
et cetera, et cetera.
And this is a fantastic push for
institutional transformation.
In the case of Germany, they--
Even the word exiles
was not used
for the people who fled Nazism.
The word [inaudible],
those who were pushed
out from their own land
was used for those who are
to leave East Germany and
were received in West Germany.
This-- even the label
recognizing
that something wrong
are being committed
against them was
not granted them.
And the same with
the case of Spain
that you saw wonderfully
exposed [inaudible].
And certainly in Spain the-- if
they have received the figures
of intellectuals, they
have tried somehow
to depoliticize them or try
to take any characteristic
that may be affecting
the view of the field.
For instance Garcia Lorca
and his sexual orientation
was somehow taken apart
and not emphasized in the
celebration of Garcia Lorca.
Finally, a word about--
and just coming to an end,
a word about the networks.
Exile opened a Pandora box
of multiple possibilities.
Again, return is just--
was just one of them.
That as Ernesto emphasized,
people leaving their countries
as part of a wave of exile
may remain and many were
in such position, may
remain attached emotionally,
intellectually to what is going
on in their country of origin.
And even if they remained
abroad, many of them try
to contribute, become members
of networks, academic networks,
intellectual networks
and political networks,
and as such they
continue to contribute
to the opening of
those societies.
And the major sign of such
opening has been the embracing
of two characteristic of
modern and Latin America.
One of them is the rural
discovery of Latin America.
This is not something new.
For instance if you
go back in history,
many of the revolutionaries
of Latin America were playing
not just with the support
of their-- of the citizens
of their own country
but with a wide range of people
coming from all other countries.
This happened in
Central America.
For instance, look at
the biography of Sandino
and who were the
lieutenants of Sandino.
And this is just one
example of many networks.
For instance, female
networks of intellectuals,
those were networks
of people building
on that transnational
identity which did not deter
from their support and
commitment to a national sense
of identity but was
combined and intertwined
with a national identity.
And so the rediscovery of Latin
America beyond the national has
been part of this
experience of exile.
And the second characteristic
is that through the dispersal
of these networks, some
of the countries have come
to the conclusion that they
should grant also political
rights to national [inaudible].
You can see that in Argentina,
you can see that in
the case of Paraguay.
And in the case of Uruguay and
Chile it's more complicated
but still there have
been attempts
to launch this connection.
On the academic field, there is
what we call the [inaudible],
the drive of those countries
to reconnect with academics,
with intellectuals,
with people who--
with professionals
staying abroad.
And this is an active effort
on the part of those country.
To sum up, to sum up, exile
has opened those countries
to globalization, to the
[inaudible] of human rights,
to rediscovery of Latin American
ties beyond their commitment
to national identities and
eventually to the possibility
that to reconsider that
the nation is broader
than the territory
of a single state.
Just to finish with one
example of that in the realm
of literature for Saúl,
[inaudible] after exile,
during and after exile,
organized a multivolume work
of critical Argentine-- critical
space of Argentine literature,
which consider for-- but
it's not the first time
but which consider in
a proper place the work
of Argentine writers
writing beyond the territory
of Argentina.
For me it has been a--
together with Saúl, with Mario
and with Leo and exercising
in long running field.
It's not a short term
but long running.
Somebody asked me how long have
you been working on this book,
and I told him, 20 years.
Oh, 20 years?
Really? Yes, multiply
five years by four.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Saúl Sosnowski:
Thank you, Luis.
He just proved that I was right
in what I said in
his introduction.
And we have time for
comments among us.
We have time for comments
and questions, observations,
rebuttals from the audience.
And the floor is open.
Let me just add one thing
in the context of exile,
and that is the contributions
that exiles themselves have
done, have made to the countries
that have hosted them.
And since Juan eloquently
spoke about Spain,
what would El Colegio
de Mexico be.
What would be the
publishing industry in Mexico
and in Argentina without the
contribution of Spanish exiles.
So this is an entirely
dynamic process
that we have to take
into account.
And, obviously, the
issue of repatriation,
the issue of return,
the issue of recognition
of exiles once they return
home when they are allowed
to return home, the flag that
justice has not been meted
out equally in each of these
countries, that the process
of returning was radically
different in each one of them.
The flag that Spain still
refuses to address major issues
such as unearthing the tombs of
those who were executed during
and after the Spanish Civil War.
These are issues that affect
us all in one way or another
and I-- They do address
some of the keywords
that appear in this book.
So hopefully we opened up
something beyond addressing some
of the issues that we wanted
to incorporate into
this first book.
The floor is open to all of you.
Gwen?
>> Milagros Peran: Yeah, OK.
Hello. My name is Milagros
Peran [assumed spelling].
I'm a Nicaraguan poet and
translator and I also happen
to have a master's from the
University of [inaudible].
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Of course.
Yes.
>> Milagros Peran: And you not--
Thank you so much because
you touched on two questions
that I have or comments
that I had.
The first one about Sandino
because he, you know,
he was sort of like
politically trained in Mexico
and he [inaudible] his ideas.
And the second one was about
the subject for the book
because when I received
this invitation,
the first thing I
thought was exile.
Something that I've
been, you know,
that I heard more
than 20 years ago.
And you just mentioned that
it took you maybe 20 years
to come up with the book.
So, that's the comment
that I wanted to make
because I remember when I was
about to publish my second book
of poetry it was in 2000.
And talked to the
professor, well,
about some of these themes.
He said, oh, exile, you know,
that was more in the '90s but,
you know, not in
the 21st century.
So, thank you so much though for
bringing this because I learned
so many things from you
today, from all of you.
It's very valid and, you know,
we have such a problem now
with amelioration
and it's everywhere.
It's everywhere.
I mean, so [inaudible] you know,
people that have been here
all their lives, and now what?
They're supposed
to go back home?
And what if they don't have,
you know, the [inaudible],
what if they forgot about that,
what are they going
to do about it?
So, thank you so much.
Wonderful.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Gwen?
>> Gwen: Yes, I was a--
thank you all very much.
A lot to think about.
I was thinking about so much of
the wonderful story of the weak
and creation and the
redemocratization.
The different points in
some of these places focuses
on the contributions of people
who went back or who were able
to form strong networks,
educate themselves, et cetera.
And I can't help thinking about
just a couple of things and--
Around 2000 there was a Chilean
TV documentary called Guevara,
the people who were often--
other parts of the world
and some of it was
fun and wonderful.
But there were a few
who had gone into exile
and was just sort of [inaudible]
up on the shore, a
mechanic in Moscow.
No-- And I think around the
characters in their novel
of Alejandro Zambra, you know,
standing on the snowy street
corner in Copenhagen and crying
because of his son who had
been separated for so long.
And I guess I just wonder how--
I mean, that sounds very pathos
and all that but it's
also part of the whole
like [inaudible] passage,
especially for those
who are less-- I think
of so many of them.
[Inaudible] immigrants that
were exiled from Central America
who were not into--
not as well situated
to have some of the [inaudible].
I just-- I wonder if
that is in a-- in--
what part it plays in your
book or probably your part or--
with the literature I guess.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: That is
the part that we are going
to write in book two, but in--
>> Luis Roniger: There is one
more in contribution in the back
and then we may address the--
>> Juan Uriagereka: Yeah,
I think he has [inaudible].
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Why not.
>> Thank you.
Happy Friday.
So I was wondering you guys
talking about the Southern Cone
and the [inaudible],
transnational ideas,
if in your research you
talked about Brazil.
If it has a model
that maybe similar
to these other Southern Cone
countries or a little different?
>> Saúl Sosnowski: OK.
Very briefly on Brazil
and then Luis can expand.
We decided at the very
beginning to exclude Brazil
because it required a different
type of treatment all together.
And that was the only
reason why we stuck
to these four countries.
Although we are all aware of
the fact that the whole wave
of coup-- coup d'etats
begin with Brazil in 1964,
that the impact it has had,
the fact that it also
received exiles from each
of the other countries.
But we decided on the
methodological basis
to leave Brazil out
of this consideration.
And in terms of what
Gwen was addressing,
the fact that some
people ended up in exile
in certain countries sometimes
was just happenstance.
It just happened.
And the moment you mentioned
the mechanic in Moscow,
I was reminded of the case of
[inaudible] who was a Tupamaro
who spent about a
decade in jail and so on.
When he got out of jail,
he ended up in Sweden.
I asked him, why did
you go to Sweden?
That was the first ticket
that was offered to me.
And in some cases
that's how it happened.
>> All right.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: So he went
to Sweden, he learned Swedish.
He published there.
He had great success
within the Swedish community
until one day he woke up and he
said, it happens to all of us
at one point, what
am I doing here?
And that he's more a literary
and he's also visual artist.
He was the director of
the National Library
and several things are very,
very interesting about him
because he broke with the
Tupamaros while being in jail
and he decided that was the
wrong approach and so on.
So I asked him, so
what happened then?
And his response was
very clear, look at me.
I interviewed him
when he was a director
of the National Library.
Pepe Mujica appointed him to
that point-- to that post.
So that indicated to the degree
to which there was a certain
openness, ideological openness,
political openness, and as well
as experience in practicality
in terms of how they
related to each other
within the Tupamaro movement
at least while in jail
and once they got out.
But he goes to Sweden because
that's where the ticket was.
Obviously the case of exiles
from the communist
party was different.
Everything was very organized
and they moved in blocks
to certain countries, to
Eastern Europe and so on.
So-- but it did vary
quite a bit.
And then there were the
cases of many people
who went wherever
they were able to go
and however they were
able to get to the border.
So, I don't think we can make
a blanket statement that--
>> No, it wasn't that--
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Yeah, I
know you weren't making that
but I was-- basically
thinking of the whole process
of how somebody will end
up in a certain place
that is not necessarily logical.
>> Ernesto Calvo: But I do,
I mean emphasize in something
that you said and the
book describes on my count
between half a million
and 800,000 exiles.
And the group of people that
the Insulsas [assumed spelling],
the Portantieros, you know,
the ones that were mentioned
are a fraction of those.
And many of those
that we are talking
about that are a fraction of
those were already Insulsa
and Portantiero before leaving.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Absolutely.
>> Ernesto Calvo: So Portantiero
had created [foreign language].
Insulsa was on his own right
already an important scholar
and when he arrived he
forms [inaudible] Mexico.
Most of them, when they arrive
from exile-- I mean on exile,
immediately they were
absorbed in the societies.
They did not train
and-- so that talks
about social capital
what was there but not
about the entire million.
There's a lot of people
that went on exile
that only face destruction
but not face the other side
of the book, you know,
the constructive part,
chapters 5 through.
And they are in a sense the
ones that only pay the cost
and have none of the benefits.
And that is sort of
a different picture.
But I do think that is
something to commend on,
on the way which
they build a book
which is generally that's the
only painting that we have.
Generally exile is
starting this way.
I mean if we think of the
contribution of that book not
as being 20-year-old but being
a roadmap for the next 20 years,
we can think that,
you know, the refugees
that we're getting today
from Syria, you know,
are going to be also
refugees in 20 years.
You can have an incredible
amount of structure
on the one hand and
an incredible amount
of human capital and
political capital that's going
to be generated.
And most people are
looking at the human costs
which are the most
important thing to focus now.
But it is true that there's
human capital to be built
and that's also an
important feature
that I think the
book does bring,
you know, very forcefully.
>> Luis Roniger:
Yes, if I may ask--
add something the label of
exile something sometimes--
something very Byronic about it.
That is maybe manipulated
as well.
We should be aware of that.
It's not by chance that we
distinguish between the exiles
of the Southern Cone and the
refugees of Central America.
Even the words that we use,
color, what we are looking for,
but we may turn as analyst,
as people who started
this phenomenon.
We may turn it being
the word of the danger
of using these labels,
we may turn it
into a tool of investigation.
And this is what I think we have
done because we find differences
between the different
diasporas in the way even
in these four cases, in
the way in which the exiles
within the community
of nationals abroad,
unless you said-- and those
are not exactly the same.
Exiles are part of a larger
community of sojourners,
of diplomats, of
students, of migrants of--
and all sorts of people
who left their countries
for different reasons.
Some for economic motivations,
others for political reasons
but still there is a core
of exiles and the question
for research is did
they became the voice
that represented the community.
And in some cases we found
that exiles spoke in the name
of all the people
who are in some way
or another forced to
leave the country.
And in other cases,
this was less prominent.
And so-- And this is
the differentiation
that we can trace in these
four cases and we trace them
and it can be also
traced in other cases.
In about Brazil,
Brazil there is a lot
of interest today
in Brazilian exile.
It started unlike of
what you were told.
It started with a book
in 1999 by a historian.
You may know her,
Denise Rollemberg.
The title of her
book is very telling.
It was called "Entre
Raizes e Radares".
This looking back and looking
forward and in the middle,
strength in the middle.
We did not touch it but
there is a large community
of people working on
the theme of exile
and return now in Brazil.
It came late, relatively late.
In the period that you
were talking about exile,
this was the period
of many testimonies,
many personal stories.
But it took another, almost
another decade or decade
and a half to reach the point
of being able to analyze
from a distance the
phenomenon of massive exile
and forced displacement.
OK.
>> Saúl Sosnowski:
One of the issues
that we also touched upon
was and that was remind--
I was reminded by your comment.
Some people when they went
overseas they had already
been established.
They had their own
signature and so on.
And they also carried wisdom
the same splits, particularly
in the case of the
Argentines, the same fractures,
the same oppositions, the same
internal fights that they had
within the country, they
carried them into exile.
And so you had even in
Mexico, you had two big groups
that we're not particularly--
>> Ernesto Calvo: A
cast was way bigger.
That's wrong in the book.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Explain.
>> Luis Roniger:
Cast [inaudible].
>> Ernesto Calvo: What?
No, no, no, no.
I was just.
I was in the cast but the
cast was in [inaudible].
>> Saúl Sosnowski: I know.
>> Ernesto Calvo:
Had way more people.
>> Saúl Sosnowski:
Yeah, that's true.
>> Ernesto Calvo: But they're
very-- [inaudible] gets more,
you know, it gets a
lot of prominence here.
>> Luis Roniger: Because
it has been researched.
>> Ernesto Calvo: Sorry.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: For the
second edition there will be a
new footnote.
>> Ernesto Calvo: Yeah,
and we will print size for.
Sorry.
>> Luis Roniger: And then--
and by the-- By the way, Saúl,
following your-- no, later.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: OK.
And the other thing is that the
children that were born there
and the impact on the
children once the possibility
of returning opened up.
And that was another
issue that we touch up on
and at least we point
to an issue
that it was quite
significant to address.
And within all of that, I would
like to stress although
Luis already has done so,
is the uniqueness of
the Paraguayan case.
Yes, it is a different
universe in terms of what it was
from the very beginning
to how the exile operated,
to how the Paraguayan
community operated,
to the fact that their most
important cultural institutions
were not based in Paraguay
but were based in exile.
And it is a way of
also marking the impact
of what the dictatorship
can have in the long term.
Namely we're talking
about the dictatorship
that is just a few years to
a dictatorship that lasted
for decades and therefore had
an impact on the entire country
that is still being felt today.
The dictatorship, the basis
for the dictatorship has not
disappeared and we see it
in the daily news
coming out of Paraguay.
The fact that Stroessner's
birthday is still celebrated
by many, that many still say
[foreign language] referring
to the fact--
>> Juan Uriagereka:
Same thing in Spain.
>> Saúl Sosnowski:
-- same as in Spain.
>> Ernesto Calvo:
Yeah [inaudible].
>> Luis Roniger: Yes.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Yeah, yeah.
Namely these are issues that
had-- that have not ended.
This is a life open channel.
So this is one of the issues
that we have to keep tackling.
It's not over.
>> Luis Roniger: Yeah.
And it's recreated
every generation.
For instance, I'm thinking
of Patricio Guzman--
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Yeah.
>> Luis Roniger:
-- as he retained--
the filmmaker from Chile.
As he returns from Chile
and shows what he has done
for all the filming for the
battala for-- batalla for Chile,
he shows to the new generations
and people are amazed.
They were not aware at all.
By the way, Patricio Guzman did
a wonderful film two years ago.
I don't know if you know it,
"El Boton de Nacar",
have you seen it?
highly recommended.
Showing that the
entire perception
of Chile being connected
to the land, to territory,
fighting the Mapuche is
a totally miscarriage
of the true identity of Chile
should be connected to the sea.
And the Mapuche were people of
the sea, not necessarily people
of the land despite their name.
>> Saúl Sosnowski:
Any comments, please.
>> Ernesto Calvo: Yeah.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: One, two.
Yes. Please
>> My name is [inaudible]
presentation.
And part of somewhere
the way you talk--
You are talking like
dictatorship is totally bad,
democracy is totally good.
But I don't see how you
explain like people are anti--
antifascism and then the
people here, they don't like it
and democracy because they don't
really have their voice heard,
then another nonvoter
as you can see.
And then I also don't see
why that our history tell us
that United Kingdom,
sometimes they explain,
sometimes there is a
construct such as China,
sometime you explain-- you have
Manchuria, you have Mongolia,
you have [inaudible]
and sometimes you
don't have that many.
And then some-- in terms of
culture, in other places,
they might [inaudible] confusion
is that the best is sent
in the world and the
people will travel far to go
to India to some Buddhism.
So that kind of [inaudible]
value I don't think you
explained in your book
or in your presentation.
You know, I just wonder if you
can comment of those if exile
or the way you intend criticism,
have you used a refugee
[inaudible] is interchangeable.
I just wonder is
the exile is really
that some people are just
sort of being influenced or--
it's not really a threat by the
political power by the influence
by the affair or in the other
way people think they have some
entrepreneurship, they
want to go overseas.
That before, several
decades ago,
people will think Brazil
is a good opportunity
for the entrepreneurship
to have a big ownership
of the big land,
something like this.
So I don't know if you
can address this issue.
>> Saúl Sosnowski:
Is it official.
Yup.
>> I work here at the
Library of Congress.
I'm just wondering,
I know Argentina
like the United States is
a country of immigrants.
I imagine all your families came
from somewhere else originally
and I wonder did you think about
that in terms of your discussion
and how might that have
affected your thoughts on--
>> Luis Roniger: Yeah, OK.
I'll start.
First of all, the questions
that you posed are far ranging
and certainly very important
from a comparative perspective.
It's a-- what we have done
is part of a larger canvas
of human mobility and you
rightly indicated that some
of that mobility is for interest
to be open to opportunities,
economic opportunities, for
instance all sorts of ways
of migration coming to Latin
America or coming to the USA,
et cetera, et cetera, and also
that the boundaries of states
in nations can expand or shrink.
So our contribution is
more modest in the sense
that we don't address
the entire range
of phenomena of human mobility.
We address especially that
part, a part of that universe
which is connected with forced
mobility or some connection
between forced mobility
and some kind of prospects
of a better life, but
especially forced mobility.
And this has been a
tradition in the societies
that we have finalized
for a very long time.
Going back to colonial times,
they were already the
[foreign language].
There was an institution of
forcing people to go out.
Not simply for political
reasons,
could be for social reasons,
for affecting the public
decorum, et cetera, et cetera.
But by the way, you
mentioned China.
Also in China the region of
Xinjiang [assumed spelling]
in the western part of
China was used as a place
of sending people who the
Chinese empire did not want
to remain because of corruption,
because of other issues.
There was also exile in China.
All empires use exile.
The UK use exile in Australia.
The Russia used exile
in Siberia.
China in Xinjiang.
So there is a longer
history even
of the narrow phenomenon
of forced exile.
Our book is about the last
half century, if you wish.
So it's more restricted.
It's more modest than the
topics that you suggested
to cover, but thank you.
And about certainly in the book
we have a section or subsection
about Jewish or half
Jewish creators.
And in that sense we connect
through their work we show
that this out-migration as
we related to other waves
of migration crossing
the Atlantic
in previous generations.
Also the phenomena of people
trying to flee a country
in disarray-- in economic
disarray which has been the case
of Argentina in the early 2000
following the economic crisis.
Many rediscovered that they were
the descendants of Spaniards,
of Italians trying to regain the
nationality of their forefathers
in order to immigrate from
a country in economy crisis.
So this is-- we-- there are
some sections of the book
in which we address that.
Especially interesting for me
is the chapter on the Jewish
or the subchapter, the
section on the Jewish
or partly Jewish authors
because they recreate
through their work the
reminiscence of their--
the diaspora of their
forefathers.
This is a-- I'm doing bad
service to the authors
but it's wonderful to
read how they reflect
on their own personal
experience in the book.
>> Ernesto Calvo:
And the book does
in the beginning
discusses immigration
in these countries
and not just exile.
>> Juan Uriagereka: Yes.
>> Ernesto Calvo:
And in quite detail.
That said in-- so in
the US and the Latino
in Argentina exile the--
in Mexico [inaudible]
so you know the--
>> Luis Roniger: Yes.
>> Ernesto Calvo: I came
to the US 20 years ago,
25 years ago now and
you know nothing of--
in fact when you introduced me,
nothing of what defines
my professional career is
in any way connected to
the fact that I am exilee.
So we have competed
in identities.
And on the book I
think it's very clear,
I'm saying that at some point
being part of exile mutated
to a lot of very
different things.
It's very clear by the end that,
you know, what you just said
about some journey, you know
this journey [inaudible]
that are taken on
different identities
and making different
roles and choices.
So, my grandfather was a
refugee from Lithuania,
actually from Vilna
and got to Argentina.
And my great grandmother died in
Auschwitz but I don't consider
that and he didn't consider
himself as an exilee
and he moved when we was 15.
And then my mother moved at 15
to Buenos Aires from [inaudible]
after the great depression
and then I moved to Argentina
when I was 15 by myself
because they were in Mexico.
So we are cut by different
identities but each one
of those movements were
in a sense different
identity formation events.
And here I think it's very clear
what they define as exilee.
That reminds me in
a way of Chris Rock,
that he has his joke
about, you know,
I used to have a job,
now I have a career.
You know I was a
dishwasher so I had a job
and now I'm a comedian
so I have a career.
So I do think there's a very
important class component--
>> Luis Roniger: Oh, yes.
>> Ernesto Calvo: -- on being
exilee rather than refugee.
>> Luis Roniger: Yeah.
>> Ernesto Calvo: And that
that's not quite describing
the book.
I mean that's why I was,
you know, mentioning.
And being an exilee in a
sense is a status symbol.
Being a refugee is a sign of
being, you know, [inaudible].
And so this is taking the most
positive and constructed--
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Totally.
>> Ernesto Calvo: And to
some extent upper elite--
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Oh,
definitely, yes, yes.
>> Ernesto Calvo: -- view exile
with not necessarily corresponds
to the million people
that weren't on exile.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Absolutely.
>> Juan Uriagereka: But there is
a testimony that you guys have.
I don't know if it is Dorfman.
I forget who it is that says
they offered me the possibility
of being an exile which
had all of consequences--
>> Luis Roniger: Dorfman.
>> Juan Uriagereka:
Dorfman, right?
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Yeah.
>> Luis Roniger: Yes.
>> Juan Uriagereka:
And I said no.
And he chose-- he made a
choice for that so-- but I've--
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Of all
the people he made the--
Dorfman was already
Dorfman before he left.
>> Juan Uriagereka: Yes.
Yes.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: So he
can afford to play that
but it's absolutely true that we
did cut across in the selection
that we have with the people
who are able to make an impact
on higher education,
in public policy,
in governmental approaches
to [inaudible],
redemocratization and so on.
There is no question that we
did leave out the majority
of the exiles who had
"the common people".
And so yes, definitely,
that is the case.
>> Luis Roniger: And
without the graciousness
of over 150 such individuals--
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Yeah.
>> Luis Roniger: -- this book
would not have been produced.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Juan was
going to say something else.
>> Juan Uriagereka:
Well, I was just going
to say a footnote on that.
Those are the people I
know for two reasons.
A, because many of
them came to Spain.
B, because I was a working
class kid so they lived
in working class neighborhoods.
In fact we faced very similar
problems including drug
addiction and things like
that but they had a level
of education that I
certainly didn't have.
So the reason they
taught us many things is
because they could.
Kind of like when this teacher
was internally exiled by Franco,
my mother learned how to read
from somebody with more culture.
So these are interesting,
unintended consequences
of these dynamics.
Yeah.
>> Saúl Sosnowski:
Yup, absolutely.
Yeah.
>> Ernesto Calvo: My
mother have medallion
of [inaudible] she
have received, so.
But yes there was
a-- And there's an--
We were in a sense a backdrop
of history but it is true
that you're talking about
a very particular group.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: You
might want to mention
who your mother was,
not just the name.
>> Ernesto Calvo: I think--
>> Saúl Sosnowski: You
mentioned the name.
>> Ernesto Calvo: Yeah, she
was a well known sequentalist
and a writer.
She had [inaudible]
10 years ago now.
>> Saúl Sosnowski: Yup.
Final word.
Thank you all.
Talia?
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzales:
Thank you.
>> Ernesto Calvo: Thank you.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzales:
[Inaudible] questions?
Well, thank you to our authors
and panelists for [inaudible].
>> Saúl Sosnowski:
Thank you [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.